here are the nominees for Best Animated
Feature Film the boss baby Tom McGrath
and Ramsey Naito the breadwinner Nora to
me and Anthony Leo Coco Ferdinand Carlos
Saldana and Lori Forte loving Vincent
Dorota cobiella Hugh Welshman and Ivan
McTaggart and the Oscar goes to
Viva Latin America
[Applause]
and
nomination for Darla K Anderson the
second win in third nomination for the
unfree
he won his first Oscar in this category
for Toy Story 3
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you to the Academy we're so happy
Coco is proof that art can change and
connect the world and this can only be
done when we have a place for everyone
and anyone who feels like an other to be
heard
this is dedicated with enormous love to
my gigantic in a woven family and most
especially my wife my rock quarry ray
love and thanks to my family my Latino
community - my husband Ryan each for
expanding my sense of what it means to
be proud of who you are and where you're
from
we hope the same thing for everyone who
connected with this film we share this
with our immensely talented cast and
crew as well as the executive teams at
Disney and Pixar thanks for the support
of my wife Laura my three kids Hannah
Alice max my entire family I love you
and the biggest thank you of all to the
people of Mexico cocoa would not exist
without your endlessly beautiful culture
and traditions
[Applause]
with cocoa we tried to take a step
forward toward a world where all
children can grow up seeing characters
in movies that look and talk and live
like they do marginalized people deserve
to feel like they belong representation
matters
muchisimas gracias a thorough seat can
view America
[Applause]